it doesn't make any sense
[Music]
it's not supposed to be this hot
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody from first
we feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by david chang he's a
restaurateur author and host of
netflix's ugly delicious as well as the
next thing you eat which you can now
watch on hulu his culinary brand
momofuku has restaurants all over the
country and has a memoir as well called
eat a peach today though he'll be eating
some scorching hot chicken wings david
chang welcome to the show sean i am i'm
honored to be here this is a
it's surreal i'm here i can't believe it
you're trapped on my show you're hostage
here and before we get going how would
you gauge your ability around spicy food
i can eat spicy problem is i'm going to
sweat profusely like probably more than
anybody's ever
sweated on your show i'm gonna sweat
from the top of my head it's gonna start
coming out everywhere
um but i can i can go after the spices
of spicy stuff but i'm still scared all
right joey diaz he's coming for your
spice crown we'll see how it goes today
david you ready to get started let's do
this
[Music]
all right
[Music]
that's a
really good wing
so your new hulu show the next thing you
eat explore something that you've talked
about for most of your career which is
what we'll be eating in 10 20 30 years
and it seems like there's so much to be
equally concerned and excited about from
burger flipping robots to r2d2 like
delivery vehicles to smoothies that can
be engineered to your dna
after going through that process what
offended you most as a chef and then
what gave you the most hope for the
future
uh
easily the most offensive is uh speaking
to these uh tech guys that are like uh
we're gonna replace you
they are
they're not even bullshitting we're
going to replace you no matter what you
make we're going to be able to make it
better
it's weird when your whole job you've
learned how to perfect this craft and
then all of a sudden you're just a
binary code to somebody
you might read in the newspaper a lot of
the the big fast food companies have
already automated they've already bought
ai
cooking machines they're getting rid of
cashiers that's already happened
so in some ways food is going to get
more efficient faster even cheaper
but i think it's going to have a bad
impact on the mom-and-pop shops right
people are going to expect
food at a level that if you're an
independent operator you're just not
going to be able to
you will be able to it's just going to
be harder it's going to be a higher
obstacle to overcome
[Music]
i'm already sweating though
good wings no complaints so far
we'll see you
so you've made podcasts and shows with
incredibly famous and fascinating people
but i don't think that i've ever seen
you more excited than when you talk to
bu professor greg blonder about
microwaves on the david chang show
to the naysayers who may be watching
right now is there a common microwave
myth that you'd like to debunk using our
platform
there's so many
that
it's going to ruin the nutrients in your
food it's going to suck all the life and
goodness out of the food and that
absolutely is incorrect
when i say it's the cleanest
most
effective way to cook something and to
retain the nutrients like it is
legitimately you can't find a better way
to cook something
it's one of the most amazing tools you
could ever use you press a button and
[ __ ] gets hot it's like that's [ __ ]
amazing to me
if you're in a kitchen and you are
pressed for time i mean you can knock
off
easy 20-30 minutes out of most recipes
preach are you ready to move on here
god damn it i'm talking about microwaves
so this next one's the hoff's hot sauce
all right
[Music]
habanero
jalapeno the habanero is going to get
you in the end though a little bit of a
tail action on that yeah
yeah it's it's coming but
it's not that bad
it's good
so in reading your memoir eat a peach
one thing that really stood out to me
was how in touch and observant you were
about the future of food media as you
saw the blogging revolution begin to
happen in real time and then one thing
that i think is kind of interesting is
that first we feast as a media brand
that continues to put out more and more
food products and then momofuku is a
food brand that continues to create more
and more media where do you think this
is all headed
i think it's at least for restaurants
and for someone like myself that's
really shifted almost completely to
doing media
we're just
always creating content i think when
you're in a restaurant and if you make
food you're creating content that is
digestible right
it's the same thing the same stories
that we're trying to tell just expanding
that universe a little bit so
i never thought when i started cooking
i'd be doing stuff like this you know
what i feel the same way when i first
started working in media i never thought
that you know one day i'd be a chicken
wing talk show host
it's gotta be
the trippiest thing
[Music]
wow
this is your own hot sauce but you know
what david chang if the palette rejects
it you let me know
you'll be honest you'll be honest
we gotta we gotta we're not leading the
way with the label here
i love this
[Music]
it's very clean first of all it's
getting some hot some heat's coming in
but it's tangy it's sweet
is there a little mustard in there
there's got to be a little mustard in
there
maybe you're catching a little apricot
there's like some
balls there
wow it's balanced
the cumin i did not expect that it's
very good oh well done i'm gonna put it
on the wing there we go
big
all right
now you've eaten a lot of wings
what is your preferred method for the
wing itself do you do one of these
jammies and push it all down so yeah
there's you know sometimes the flat like
they'll do the bone split thing and then
you can kind of just
rip it like that so that would be my
preferred way and just so the casual
outside of this show thing but what i
find in doing the show there's kind of a
cadence and a rhythm to like you know
you eating the wing enjoying the wing
maybe you have a comment about the wing
but then i have to start the question so
i kind of just
get in where i can fit in try to swallow
it as fast as i can without choking
which earlier this season i got
lodged right in the windpipe with john
bernthal sitting across from me on the
first wing so a lot of plates spinning
on this side of the table david i i
don't want your job it seems incredibly
difficult
i'm i'm sweating you're not sweating at
all not yet not yet i'll get there i
mean my top my head is already sweating
it's wet
you guys gonna see some crazy crazy
crazy moisture come out
[Music]
i've always watched clips of the one you
do with ramsay yeah it makes me think
he's just a wimp
i mean he was like freaking out right
around here
yeah you know dj khaled famously tapped
out on the third one
well you can't trust those djs
so one of the most popular occurring
segments on the david chang show is my
opinion is fact which is basically just
a free-for-all of topics and food hot
takes that can go anywhere so in lieu of
explaining that graham today what i want
to do is play a little game myself where
i'll just hit you with some broad food
topics and you just kind of hit me with
the first spice fuel thoughts that come
to mind does that sound good my mouth is
really warming up
here we go
pumpkin pie it's disgusting
it's gourd
it's a [ __ ] gorge
it's
nobody eats it any other time of year
right nothing gets me more worked up
than goddamn pumpkin pie
it should be barred nobody should ever
make it ever again and
you know starbucks has just ruined
coffee with that goddamn abomination
pumpkin spice latte
it's a [ __ ] gourd nobody eats gourds
do you eat gourds i don't eat gourds i
promise you i promise you i do not eat
cords see
i get mad i get mad thinking about
pumpkins
australian burgers
that's got me a lot of trouble because
i'm right they're terrible
they got great sports they can drink
extraordinary amounts of alcohol but
they can't make a goddamn burger because
they put beets on it that's just a cop
that's an unholy combination that is not
needed but
aussies swear by it and i think it's
like stockholm syndrome or something
yelp
oh man i don't know where to begin
there are some really good yelpers out
there
but doesn't mean just because they have
elite thing they know what the hell
they're talking about
and i know just by talking about this
now they're gonna go online and they're
gonna give me one stars at all of my
[ __ ] restaurants
i think every yelper should pass some
kind of driver's license i'm down with a
select few people that know what they're
talking about do you agree or disagree
no you know what actually uh thanks for
asking the question because i find that
these sorts of when it when it becomes
over democratized in the review i find
the reviews to be not so helpful because
i'm a big delivery guy no i'm a big
delivery guy and sometimes i'll feel
like they'll give something a one star
because they didn't have the the
silverware included in the carryout bag
and i was like well that does me no good
or the food was like a little bit late
but i don't mind the food's late i want
to know is it good or not or they think
that it's like too expensive so i think
these little things that people get
angry about they then project that anger
onto the review but as somebody who just
wants to know if the food's good or not
i find that i'm like you're not being
helpful and then these one stars they'll
drag down the average so then i'll feel
like you know these people that are
angry about something that has nothing
to do with the food is not serviceable
to me at all as somebody's scrolling
through there i'm like get these people
out of here so i agree with you 100 you
should run for office god damn it
that was [ __ ] beautiful man
[Music]
this labeling actually scares me
it's it's very simple they're not trying
to shock you with skulls and crossbones
i think this is gonna and it's ghost
pepper clearly it's gonna it's gonna
it's gonna hurt yep
it's got that tastes like ghost pepper
so recently uh pete wells review in the
new york times went viral when it took
aim at three michelin star restaurant 11
madison park for its pivot to vegan menu
and i won't ask you about reviews of
other restaurants or chefs but i am
curious more generally speaking broadly
where do you see fine dining's place and
influence in the wake of the pandemic
i think fine dining is necessary
in every city and every place we eat
because we need diversity right
uh and a lot of things do trickle down
from the top so a fine dining restaurant
doesn't always but oftentimes has the
best most ambitious cooks
and
a lot of those ideas a lot of those
cooks that work there
learn the best techniques learn how to
operate and run a restaurant they may
not ever run that kind of restaurant
themselves but they'll be able to take
that kind of training it's like high
it's like grad school so whether you
like fine dining or not and a lot of
people don't like it because it's
expensive it's extravagance but it's
crucial to the the the lifeblood and
like the vibrancy of a city's cuisine
for sure
oh scorpion pepper
[Music]
scotch bonnet
there's no friend of mine
but again like i can i can
i can i can live with this you're doing
great going back in
all right i am sweating
that's nice a nice hot ones glow a nice
hot one's glue
so i've heard that many independent
restaurants can only last about 10 days
of being closed before the whole thing
bottoms out what are some tangible
things that diners can do to ensure the
restaurants that they love stick around
you should choose three to five
restaurants that you are going to
support you can't support everyone
choose three to five and have
you know the fourth or sixth spot in
your rotation constantly
evolving and changing
but choose three to five get to know
them
when you get to know the proprietary
proprietors of the restaurant the people
that work there you get treated like
family
everyone's like i gotta do this whole
world i gotta save everything no no like
get your spots
and support them unconditionally
wise words are you ready to move on to
this next one this is the bomb beyond
insanity and it is a wild one i mean i
have
pepper oils
all over my face
this is gonna hurt huh let's see here
mostly habanero
it doesn't have ghost pepper
there's something going on with this one
though
all right all right all right let's
listen you can only
it's hard to explain
that's a lot of happening yeah
[Music]
what
is happening
is this a bizarre culinary experience
that you're having right now it almost
feels like the mushrooms are kicking
doesn't make any sense
it's way hotter than it should ever be
for a habanero habaneros are eating
habaneros
[ __ ] me man
so when you're not being nice guy chiang
for anyone who's trying to survive as a
restaurant what is your real opinion
of the endless number of momofuku
rip-offs that have entered the market
over the last 15 plus years
oh man
it's weird to go to another place and
see
some dish that you've made
or some concept that you've been working
on
and now i get why
people start to pause around this time
holy help
[Music]
when i was younger it used to irritate
the hell out of me but then i realized i
didn't really come up with anything you
know what i mean like i've taken plenty
of ideas we all do like we're influenced
by everything
and
if they can run with it and do it better
great
i mean this business is too [ __ ] hard
so whatever
they can do to stay in business and to
thrive then i'm all for it
but i used to be a lot more obnoxious
about it and i'm i'm just
a lot more understanding of it now
how you feeling
hurts man
but
i was like you know what i'm going to
take another bite of that
i'm not going to take another bite all
right all right cause i mirrored the gas
so i was a little bit nervous right
there that is just
doesn't make any sense
it's not supposed to be this hot
[ __ ]
[Music]
i mean have you won an emmy yet
no i got nominated what the hell emmy
[Laughter]
i got nominated this year but uh no this
is maybe more difficult being a wartime
correspondent like this is this is crazy
[ __ ]
you're right you're right and you know
what the the media brand
should you know consider the hazard pay
of it all you know yeah you're really
risking life and limb here
all right
god damn it
that's that's just too hot
i thought i was gonna be so badass i was
gonna be like doing this and
no none of that is happening but this
again the scares this bottle is trying
to scare you
[Music]
but just going in anyway
[Music]
whoa
i can't taste anything it doesn't matter
different completely different than the
habanero in a in a better way or a worse
way
it's
it's a punch in the face and this is a
kick in the balls
but if there's different
sweating is happening now
it's the full physiological experience
of hot ones here full physiological
experience i'm literally sweat is just
dripping off my face
so we started first we feast as a
website one of our flagship series
featured chefs talking about the dishes
that made their career what do you think
it is about the pork buns of momofuku
that makes them like the culinary
equivalent to a stadium anthem
i literally took it because i was eating
at oriental garden and i was eating
peking duck and i was like oh this would
be this is like a mini hamburger
and we were it wasn't on the original
menu
we just were going out of business and
we needed to find new ways
of like selling stuff
i had no idea that people were going to
resonate with it and i think maybe
because it was handheld i had some
pickle cucumbers in there the hoisin
sort of acted as a as a analogy
parallel to ketchup and i just feel like
when people ate it they were like eating
a hamburger
that's that has to be the case
so
i mean
it was just an accident quite frankly
all right david chang
i see this on your shoulder i never
realized it was your hot one yeah yeah
the apollo pepper channels the sun's
energy to bring new levels of flavor and
heat to the world of super hots
live the hot ones tradition
this is a good branding job oh wow
i'm loving the uh i'm loving the brand
compliments from you today david all
right
let's
like really get this in here yeah oh
whoa whoa whoa
all right
we're going out
we're going out with a bang
oh that's [ __ ] hot
oh man
[Music]
that was [ __ ] stupid
ah
i didn't know apollo pepper was an
actual pepper yeah
we actually invented it for the sauce
we have a pepper grower smoking head
curry [ __ ]
crossbreeding peppers
specifically for this moment
but the good news the good news david
chang is that we've reached the end of
your life that's how you call protesters
[Laughter]
the good news david chiang as we've
reached the end of our long overdue date
with the wings of death together and to
close things out what we did is we
reached out to a few people in the chang
inner circle with their questions for
david chang so here as you work through
that sauce i'm gonna direct your
attention to the monitor for a very
special video question and our first one
from quan
all right david chang now i got a
question for you think hard all right
what would you rather have splashed on
you
now the liquid that's in a porta potty
which is used by the way or
the liquid that drips from the back of a
garbage truck
and carved
claw man what the hell man
come over that if i have the answer i'm
going over the garbage truck i think
that's the only move that's i mean i can
look at a garbage truck i can't even
look at a porta potty
all right one more this one is from
wiley [ __ ]
hey dave i can see you're busy but uh
quick question
what are the five mother sauces
let me give you a hint one of them is
not hot sauce
i can't think right now
this
that was the great chef wiley dufrey
who hates spicy food by the way
and i'm just a
god damn it
what's funny as i ask this to my cook
[ __ ] blanket out right now oh my god
you have mornay
you have bechamel you have hollandaise
you have um
there's a tomato compote one there and
then there's another one
it is espanol sauce
which is the one i always remember
because it's like why the [ __ ] is that a
french word
god damn it
david chang nailing the quiz from wiley
at the end of our episode taking on the
wings of death and conquering and now
david chang there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
oh man i got so much going on we just
had a new cookbook come out called
cooking at home
and
we had the hulu show and we launched
um some actually hot stuff of our own
the momofuku extra spicy chili crunch
it's for you i love
when i get some gifts some spicy we have
some noodles out there as well you can
get those anywhere you buy noodles um
but we're
we're um we're doing what you're doing
now we're just diversifying
[Applause]
[Music]
that was so much hotter than i was
expecting
[Music]
well i am honored thank you for having
me
look at dom always coming through
dom's always coming through with the
lifelines thank you so much
how was that i have no idea what
happened
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement you know after 16
seasons i'd like to think that we
perfected the hot sauce symphony and now
i gotta hand it to us
we perfected the packaging it's the
custom-made hot ones official 10-pack
briefcase now available at heatness.com
take a look inside it's so pretty and
the perfect gift for the spice lord in
your life just get some friends make
some wings bring some ice cream and be
careful around the eyes heatness.com
heatness.com to get your hands on the
custom-made hot ones official 10-pack
briefcase
i know i love it
[Music]